monsieur le Président de la collectivité
territoriale mais ce les parlementaires
monsieur le Président de l'Association
des Maires Mesdames et Messieurs les
élus les maires les conseillers de la
collectivité territoriale et les membres
des corps intermédiaires chers citoyenne
Guyane mesdames messieurs nous voilà une
nouvelle fois réunis en congrès une
énième fois plein d'espoir optimiste sur
l'issue des travaux et pourtant cet
après-midi nous nous quitterons avec
autant de questions qu'on arrivons
l'espoir en moins je suis désolé de
plomber l'ambiance mais vous connaissez
ma façon de parler il est grand temps de
crever l'abcès il est temps de nous
parler avec franchise pour moi c'est
congrès s'apparente aux mythe de
Sisyphes condamnés a poussé pour
l'éternité un énorme rocher jusqu'en
haut d'une montagne le mythe de Sisyphe
symbolise une tâche interminable et
ardues qu'il faut toujours recommencer
pour un résultat incertain ce qui nous
EMP précédé juste un cataï et
george-t-il il léopolither on fait le
même constat que nous la Guyane mérite
un statut spécial nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à jouer avec souvenir de notre
pays et cette évolution est nécessaire
tous ensemble nous voulons un projet qui
permettra de déterminer le cadre
économique politique et administrative
de notre territoire un projet qui nous
ressemble et qui nous rassemble mais
depuis des décennies nous sommes
incapables d'avoir ce dialogue patient
nous sommes incapables de rassembler nos
énergies dans le respect des convictions
politiques et idéologiques des uns et
des autres pire c'est congrès voir les
différentes réunions auxquelles nous
sommes invités à assister servent bien
souvent de calendrier politique pour
certains nous devons avoir le courage
politique pour rechercher de manière
obstinée un bon compromis entre les
positions des uns et des autres nous
devons avoir la maturité politique pour
parler d'une seule voix face au
gouvernement l'état connaît nos
divisions l'État ne sait que trop bien
que nous sommes incapables de nous
entendre sur les sujets importants nos
mésentente notre désunion joue notre
défaveur et cela depuis trop longtemps
quand le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer dit que la question de la
réforme institutionnelle n'intéresse que
les élus et pas la population mais c'est
tout simplement parce qu'ils se fonde
sur notre impuissance à nous transcender
sur ce dossier important nous
transcendez et aller au-delà de nos
différences politiques
très capacité à intéresser la population
à cette question mais comment convaincre
les Guyanais quand nous leur proposons à
longueur de journée l'image d'une classe
politique divisée je ne suis pas adepte
de la pensée unique loin de là la
pluralité voudrait que nous défendions
tous des idées qui nous sont propres qui
nous sont chers mais j'insiste là-dessus
nous devons considérer que le courage
politique voudrait que nous tous
ensemble nous mettons les intérêts de la
Guyane avant tout ambition personnelle
nous ne pouvons plus continuer à dire à
la population que l'État est le seul
responsable de la situation actuelle de
la Guyane nous ne pouvons plus continuer
à nier notre implication dans les échecs
passés oui l'état ça part de
responsabilité mais nous aussi nous
avons la nôtre nos calculs politiciens
nous ont conduit dans cet dans cet
impact voilà plus de 50 ans au bas mot
que nous requérant un statut spécial qui
s'y est à notre situation géographique
et à notre désir de développement nous
ne pourrons prétendre à plus d'autonomie
en démontrant au
aussi ajouté demain il serait peut-être
trop tard chers élus faisant en sorte
qu'ils soient pas trop tard pour nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants je vous
souhaite de passer un bon débat bon
congrès et puis que nous restions tous
ensemble que nous parts que nous parce
que nous partageons la même le même
objectif c'est pour développer notre
pays et encore une fois donnons-nous la
main pour que en face de nous nous
puissions avoir un gouvernement qui
qui réagissent qui réagissent face à
nous tout simplement merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]